[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and so
the second half of 2013 is set to be
pretty awesome with the amount of
flagships we're expecting to see from
here on out you know the nokia lumia
1020 is right around the corner the
press has been losing their minds over
the moto x and this year we'll also see
you know the next iphone the next nexus
etc but there's one device that i'm
personally more excited about than well
any other and no one really seems to be
talking about it yet maybe it's because
it's too early but if i have to be the
only one that hypes up this device so be
it but i'm really excited for the
samsung galaxy note 3. now this might
not apply to everyone but i'm feeling
like the galaxy note 3 is going to be
that first device in a long time that
doesn't have any major flaws that
obviously hold it back now it's not like
every device that's ever come out has
had a major flaw but there are some
almost perfect devices out there right
now for example the htc one it's an
amazing device and it's really good in a
lot of ways it's almost perfect but i
feel like that battery life has held it
back for me and then there's a galaxy s4
again an impressive device in a lot of
ways but you know touchwiz has held it
back and the build quality has really
been a problem for me and even the nexus
4 is another awesome example of a great
phone but you know how not having lte is
also a pretty big downside so i feel
like the note 3 with all the
expectations we have for it with all the
things that we are expecting to get out
of this phone
might be the one first thing we're
expecting is an updated display
somewhere in the neighborhood of 5.8
inches and of course at least 1920 by
1080. now you can ask a lot of people
and they will all tell you probably that
5.8 inches is too big to be a smartphone
it's incredibly large compared to you
know the iphone and of course all the
other smaller phones out there but ask
anyone else who was using a note 2 just
like me we got used to it it's so easy
to get used to a 5.6 inch or 5.5 inch
display that especially having a larger
display all that extra real estate just
becomes something you get used to and
every other phone seems small so ask
anyone else like i said who's used the
note 2 they'll probably say the same
thing and of course the pixel density on
the current galaxy note 2 is a little
bit low it's only 1280 by 720 but now
with all these 1080p panels out
shouldn't be a problem to get a really
nice high resolution at least 1080p
display on the galaxy note 3 which is
going to be awesome because you know i
love pixels i'm also going to give it
bonus points for me personally because i
have big hands and i use large phones i
happen to like larger phones for that
exact reason they just fit more
comfortably in the hand i can't use an
iphone it feels like a toy when i'm
holding it in my larger hands so yeah
big phone big screen that works next
thing we're expecting is the operating
system android 4.2 or maybe even 4.3 if
it's out by then i'm expecting the
latest version of android will touchwiz
slow it down
probably uh but obviously a lot of the
galaxy note features will rely on that
samsung builds a lot of new interesting
stuff into touchwiz but if this is
anything like the galaxy s4 i will not
have a problem with cyanogenmod i rooted
and flashed cyanogenmod on my galaxy s4
a couple of weeks ago and i have been so
much happier with it the performance is
better the battery life has improved and
i don't miss any of the samsung air
features at all and some people might
love those features i don't miss them so
i'll be using cyanogenmod a lot of
people will also realize that since it's
a galaxy note 3 we're talking about here
there's also going to be a stylus just
like all the other galaxy notes and i'm
thinking that unless there are some
really impressive things going on with
that stylus that require touchwiz
i won't even give it a chance i'll
probably go straight to cyan engine my
when it's available next we're expecting
power so much power we're expecting this
galaxy note 3 to launch with the
qualcomm snapdragon 800 a bit of a
legendary processor in itself that
system on a chip isn't really shipping
in very many devices yet but when it
does it pretty much creates the top of
the line device when you put a
snapdragon 800 in something it becomes
awesome the galaxy note 2 was already a
really high-end device it was the first
quad-core one with lte to hit the united
states this galaxy note 3 is going to be
another flagship and all i really want
to tell you is that you know expect quad
core at least expect you know 1.8
gigahertz at least the specs don't
really matter all that much it's going
to have at least 2 gigabytes of ram but
bottom line is this is going to be an
insanely powerful device just like the
galaxy note 1 and note 2 were in their
time not really much else to say about
that other than i'm really excited for
the snapdragon 800 and then we're
expecting the battery the galaxy note 2
already had a huge battery you know we
expected a large device with lots of
room inside to have a big battery and it
did of course pull that off with a 3 100
milliamp hour battery one of the biggest
in any smartphone still today one year
later and i'm expecting no less from the
galaxy note 3. with big powerful
internals it's got to have a big
powerful battery and i'm expecting at
least 3100 milliamp hours to power the
galaxy note 3 all day every day for a
road warrior like me it's got to be a
big battery and i have no problems with
samsung making that happen i have no
doubts in this kind of like when the
battery in the back of your smartphone
is already the size of another phone the
iphone
it's kind of hard to argue with that
it's a massive battery powers it like
all day if you don't use it that much
you can have like this as a two day
phone you can take it for a weekend and
not charge it i'm done all i want to say
is great battery the note 3 should also
take the camera from the galaxy s4 which
is already a great one one of the best
in any smartphone to date and i also
expect a larger speaker because the
galaxy s4 doesn't have a very big
speaker so what about the build that's
one of the last and one of the most
important things that would make this a
drool worthy device is the build and
well honestly i'm expecting something
like a galaxy s4 eyes galaxy note 2. let
me explain so when samsung went from the
galaxy s3 to the galaxy s4 they pulled
off the miracle where they shrunk the
actual size of the device made the bezel
smaller and actually made the entire
device thinner and managed to fit a
bigger screen and larger battery in this
slightly smaller device i'm expecting
the same thing with the galaxy note 3
when you compare it to galaxy note 2.
i'm expecting again that slightly larger
display slightly bigger battery slightly
thinner form factor and overall sexiness
bonus points ceramics or metal ditch the
plastic and you win the hearts of so
many people samsung i'm not expecting it
fully from samsung at all but there's
been little talks and little renders of
you know ceramic and metallic looking
galaxy note 3s and all of them look sexy
so basically what i'm trying to say is
i'm more excited for the galaxy note 3
than i am for a lot of the other
upcoming leaked and talked about
flagships that are upcoming this year
maybe you're excited about something
else definitely feel free to leave your
thoughts in the comment section right
below that like button it is always open
you can probably see me typing away in
the comments section answering you guys
but let me know what you're excited for
maybe it's the next iphone maybe it's
the next nexus maybe it's the moto x
maybe it's something i didn't even talk
about in this video definitely feel free
to let us all know either way thank you
for watching feel free to subscribe if
you want to see more videos like this
without any further ado i'll go ahead
and sign off thanks again and i'll talk
to you in the next one
peace
[Music]
you